Hi Terry
Hi sprite whitman you get to see your aunt
because i think she started a presentation
about the importance of apex predators in our
ecosystem that's ironic since she helped wipe
out an entire species of them what species
did sersi have to wipe out deviants you see
this right here this was a deviant's head
well actually it's the head of a smilodon
a genius of the extinct macroedontony subfam
why can't they ever get thena's likeness right
it's uh it's ah ah just thena no a
see that spear she's holding in
real life it's made of cosmic energy
cosmic energy she's like family to me really
what's your power then i make illusions
the reason humans are at the top of the food
chain is because you believe in structures
and principles that don't actually exist
gods nations money all concepts stories
illusions i guess who taught them to you
me you do know an awful lot for your age
i'm older than you think so i hear
you've asked sersi to move in with you
it has been discussed cool listen
there are some things you should know
she's not over her ex-boyfriend they broke
up a century ago he's hot and he can fly
look
i know you don't like us dating
it must be hard growing up without
parents sersi being all that you have
but i love her and i promise
not to take her away from me
well fine go for it then
well what is it
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
marvel eternals deleted scene marvel's finally
started dropping a lot of the deleted scenes
because the movie's coming out on disney plus
this week there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything and i know there's
a lot of questions about what's happening with
kit harington's black knight character next i
will talk about that during the video too i've
already done videos for the post-credits scene
so i will link those in the description below
but if it wasn't clear this scene is taking
place right after sersi shows up late to her
class at the beginning of the movie to find
dane whitman's black knight character who's
making this big metaphor about the seat of
perfection being nestled inside the earth
it is meant to very overtly foreshadow the reveal
of tiamat the new celestial growing inside the
earth and causing all the earthquakes as he gets
ready to emerge thus they call it the emergence
in the movie celestial is literally bursting from
inside the earth in the whole seed metaphor is all
about airshown the judge's celestial seas that
he sends to galaxies all over the universe to
birth new celestials so that they in turn will
birth new galaxies themselves causing the main
mcu universe to continue existing if the celestial
stopped cold turkey and didn't create any more new
galaxies like if they all died right now as long
as you believe what ayershim is saying some of
what he says are lies the main mcu universe would
theoretically begin to slowly die of heat death
and it would still take billions of years for
that to happen like all the current existing suns
in galaxies that contain life would have to die
first like our son in the soul galaxy in real life
still has about another 10 billion years before it
reaches the end of its life so we've got a little
bit of time before we have to worry about the
universe dying the connection to the loki series
and he who remains version of kang is that he's at
the end of the timeline implying that eventually
all the celestials will die at some point in the
future of the mcu because here in this place where
he is he is literally the last remaining living
being in the universe that's why he's called he
who remains he and his citadel at the end of time
here on this rock are the only things that remain
in the main mcu universe so after sersi shows
up and starts talking about the concept of apex
predators in the ecosystem dane whitman leaves and
finds sprite here where this deleted scene picks
up and at this point in the timeline he hasn't
learned anything about the eternals yet so he
believes the story that sprite and sersi have been
telling everyone that she's her niece and they've
been acting like she's her guardian because at
least till the end of the movie she had never aged
so they had to create this fake backstory that
they told everyone everywhere they moved across
time if it wasn't clear too at the end of the
movie sersi uses the last of the extra uni mind
energy that they gained from tiamat to transform
her into a more humanoid form so sersi and the
eternals were already fairly powerful in their own
right they had a certain amount of cosmic energy
but it took the extra power up of the unimine
where she basically took the power of all of
them combined and the new celestial power coming
from tiamat like a massive massive battery of
cosmic energy and took all that and used most of
the energy to transform him into a stone celestial
like he's fully stoned now but also then use a
little bit of that to change sprite into a human
but sprite is still technically an eternal she has
her powers at the end of the movie sersi just made
it so that she can age and die like humans that's
also the easy way they explain child actor liam
mchugh being way older looking way older the
next time they bring eternals characters back
in a future mcu movie in this deleted scene the
reason she's so hostile towards kit harington's
dane whitman black knight character especially
at the beginning of the movie too isn't because
she hated him it's more about her being mad
at sersi for getting involved with a human
in all the complications that it might cause for
them and she was also kind of jealous at sersi for
a bunch of different reasons like she resented her
one because she looked like an adult and therefore
was capable of having romantic relationships with
other adults and two because sprite had been in
love with ikaris this whole time for thousands of
years but ikaris had been in love with sersi so
they had this weird love quadra angle thing going
on with sersi the black knight ikaris and sprite
if you didn't pick up on that during the movie
that's why at the end of the movie sprite sided
with ikaris even though it was pretty clear that
he was not a lolicon like there was never going to
be anything between the two of them even if they'd
been successful at the end of the film and team it
had emerged destroying the earth but during this
deleted scene you can see sprite just messing with
the black knight basically giving away all the
eternals and celestial secrets in not so subtle
ways like she really wants him to go away just
leave sersi like that's why she's trying to freak
him out with all these facts like later in the
movie she had another version of this scene where
she's referencing sersi's previous relationship
with ikaris it implies that some of what sersi has
told him about ikaris was a total lie like in this
scene she very literally says oh he can fly even
though kit harington's black knight is listening
to her taking it more metaphorically like oh he's
a pilot but that was all meant to set up the big
deviance reveal where ikaris does show up to help
them and we get our big game of thrones reunion
between jon snow and rob stark next time i see
you you'll be all in black it was always my colour
it's funny how that worked out next time they did
see each other he was the black knight so he was
technically dressed in black and for reference
the writers were very clear at the end of the
movie ikaris did die when he flew into the sun
he flew too close to the sun literally fulfilling
the greek legend of ikaris which we learned was
a story fabricated by sprite when the eternals
lived in ancient greece see also kind of tells
dane whitman that as they're going around and
she's pointing out the historical inconsistencies
in the museum like all those things that you
know about that came from me pretty much all
the greek legends were created by sprite even
though there is a version of zeus the god in
the mcu we're actually going to meet him in thor
love and thunder he'll be played by russell crowe
he's not as powerful as odin but he's still
very powerful and marvel does have versions of
actual greek gods like that's where the hercules
character comes from for those of you that want
to see mcu hercules show up in the movies at some
point the only thing she's really wrong about here
when she's talking to him is the idea that gods
don't exist because they do exist we know about
odin thor hella they are actual gods in the mcu
are you thor the god of hammers hmm the reason why
i think they had this line in the movie though
was to foreshadow the big twist with the truth
of the celestials like the eternals start the
movie worshiping the celestials and heirshim as
gods but we find out that all the celestials are
just extremely powerful cosmic beings that are
themselves part of a larger system like the idea
that they themselves were created by eternity the
living embodiment of the multiverse so the whole
idea in this deleted scene in the beginning of the
film is that they're trying to set up the concept
that there's always a bigger fish out there
when she starts to freak out here though that's
when the earthquake started happening right at
the beginning of the film in the middle of
sersi's lecture about apex predators setting
up the big teammates celestials reveal about the
emergence and i know there's a lot of questions
about what's happening with kit harington's black
knight character next i've already done a couple
post credit scene videos i'll link those in the
description below but kit harington's character
implies that throughout the whole movie like
this whole time that he's been going out with
sersi dating her he's known about the ebony blade
the curse of his family the lineage of the black
knight and he just kept it secret from her the
same way that she kept her secrets of the eternals
from him there's a scene at the end of the movie
where he's about to tell her his secret like you
know i've had this very complicated family history
just as heirsham the judge shows up and takes all
the eternals back to the world forge where he
created them but the funny thing is that the
eternals already knew all about the ebony blade in
the black knight way before this sersi herself at
the beginning of the film gave dane whitman his
family's ancestral ring as a gift she lied about
finding it on ebay when really she probably just
kept it over the centuries the eternals lived in
camelot so in the mcu camelot king arthur all
those characters like merlin were real people
merlin was probably the sorcerer's supreme of
his era merlin created the ebony blade that's
why when they go back to the domo their ship and
they have all those artifacts all over the place
the trophies that they've collected along the
years athena sees a sword and sprite asks is that
the ebony blade she says no that's excalibur as in
the actual mythological excalibur so if it wasn't
clear sersi the eternals knew the original sir
percy black knight character because they lived
in camelot when all that was going down during the
fall of camelot the sir percy black knight is just
dane whitman's ancestor so they know all about the
curse of the ebony blade and obviously marvel will
cover all that history the backstory we'll learn
more about the original black knight when we see
kit harington show up next actually wielding the
blade in the full black knight armor the voice
speaking to him in the post-credits scene was
actually mahershala ali's blade character it's
the first scene ever in the mcu with a brand new
blade so they're implying that the black knight
will be in the new blade movie like black knight
vampire hunter which i think makes sense he's a
very dark very magic based character so he fits
well in more supernatural stories what'll happen
though is after they release the eternals on
disney plus later this week i might do another
video for eternals starfox thanos a bunch of other
cool eternals easter eggs in the mcu but while you
wait for everything click here for my brand new
spider-man andrew garfield announcement about him
coming back for more movies and click here for
that thor love and thunder first look at rune
king thor thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!